i'm so regularly asked do you talk to
your dad the most common question i
think is people wanting to know if we
reconnected because of the trial or
because of my divorce
lindsay chrisley opens up about
reconnecting with her dad todd chrisley
an event that wasn't always in the cards
there will never be
a reconciliation
the former reality star breaks it down
for listeners of her podcast the
southern tea i'm so regularly asked do
you talk to your dad i feel like i
finally do need to answer this things
haven't always been peachy and we've had
to fight our battles publicly
one of those battles lindsey and todd's
family drama following her exit from
chrisley knows best in 2019.
there was just some kind of emotional
battle that lindsay has had within
herself more recently todd and julie
chrisley await sentencing after losing
their fraud trial in june and last year
lindsey and husband will campbell split
after nine years of marriage it's like i
told my dad the other day sometimes when
you don't speak about something you
become the loudest person in the room
so with that in mind lindsay decides to
set the record straight
the most common question i think is
people wanting to know if we reconnected
because of the trial or because of my
divorce
and i can
confidently tell you there was no
reconnection due to any legal
reasons whatsoever nothing like that
ever
transpired
as lindsay tells it their reconciliation
began with a supportive message on
social media but after my
divorce um stuff had become public
my dad had posted i'm here i love you
whatever's going on in your life right
now i see it so that's really more so
how we were able to reconnect so to
answer that question in short
it was definitely because of my divorce
but just this past september lindsay
told e.t the message wasn't something
she cared about and there was no clear
path to repairing their relationship
i feel that if it was something that was
from a genuine place then
it should have been private and not
on instagram there will never be
a reconciliation
i think that um the most that
anyone could ask for at this point is
for everyone to go on with their lives
as they see fit and
to just leave
the other
side alone fast forward to 2022 lindsay
testified on todd and julie's behalf at
their ultimately doomed trial
where they were convicted of conspiracy
to commit bank fraud bank fraud
conspiracy to defraud the united states
and tax fraud
with julie also receiving an additional
conviction for wire fraud
it's a very sad
um heartbreaking time for our family
right now but we still hold steadfast in
our faith
todd and julie shared their reaction on
their own podcast following the verdict
we're alive and kicking and uh we
appreciate all of the support that we
have received um from everyone it's
the
love that is
spread so far throughout this country
for our family
is is what's truly helping us to get up
each day